hey everyone I'm Meg from Fandango movie
clips with my top ten films of 2014
let's kick off the new year right by
reflecting on the best films of the past
year number 10 the drop the best
thriller of the year starring Tom Hardy
Noomi Rapace and the king james
gandolfini this film had me on the edge
of my seat the whole time with its
clever twists and turns I don't need to
see what's in that bag I was practically
screaming at the screen when I thought
they were gonna kill that adorable puppy
let's be real whatever shows that John
wick Busey number 9 edge of tomorrow
live die watch on repeat Tom Cruise you
may be a crazy bastard but you're still
one hell of an action star things gonna
start over it was Groundhog Day Meets
Mission Impossible and I was blown away
by how perfectly it was pulled off
however the marketing team must have
been stuck in the same time loop as
crews because they kept trying to come
up with a title that made sense but
still couldn't get it right number 8 the
most delicious movie of the year
chef's warning do not watch hungry I was
craving a Cuban sandwich so hard after
this I almost hopped on a plane to me on
me me and me me and me I get to touch
people's lives with what I do
Jon Favreau has proven himself as a
fantastic director and actor obviously
Ironman roles but this puts him on a
whole other level
number seven Wes Anderson to the grand
Budapest hotel possibly my favorite of
his film it's filled with delightful
sets colorful backdrops and loads of
symmetry surprise surprise but Budapest
gives us even more with its intriguing
and crafty plot the police are here tell
them I'll be right there
it almost made me reassess my play has
it become an old bridge cougar yeah
number 6 dawn of the Planet of the Apes
let me break it down the CGI incredible
it'll never happen but any circus
deserves an Oscar let's rally let's get
it done
and and I'm not sure what made me cry
more an injured Caesar returning to his
childhood home baby monkey number
five-mile Dallas buyers club director
Jean buck Valle flawlessly brings a
popular book of the same name to scream
no makeup no instructions and no clothes
Reese Witherspoon gets the best
performance of her career and helps me
get in touch with my wild side
number four boyhood turns out nothing
more powerful than witnessing a boy grow
up in front of your eyes twelve year old
me with braces and a unibrow would beg
to differ
but thankfully for Ellar Coltrane the
risk was worth it how was your week
you know you do hang out with you have a
girlfriend I've always considered
richard linklater a genius director but
this film cements him is one of the
greatest working today see you point
number three birdman alejandro gonzález
in your v2 transports his audience into
the semis surrealist world of x action
star Regan Thompson played perfectly by
ex action star Michael Keaton working
with brick until instants like walking
with a monkey huh I might have said yeah
I was super impressed by the long takes
raw performances but most of all by Emma
Stone's protruding eyeballs
number two guardians of the galaxy james
gunn delivers the perfect combination of
action humour and abs thanks to our
favorite gang in misfits we now know the
best way to defeat an intergalactic
villain is serenade him with a classic
jams song dance go no three
and my number one movie of the year is
whiplash miles teller and JK Simmons
literally poured blood sweat and tears
into their oscar-worthy performances did
I ask you to start playing again even
Eli Roth was like damn this movie is
perfect period who know music school is
so terrifying one two three rushing or
dragging rushing so you do know the
difference
it gets my vote for Best Picture once
again my top ten movies of the year are
the drop edge of tomorrow
[ __ ] the grand Budapest hotel dawn of
the Planet of the Apes wild boyhood
Birdman guardians of the galaxy and
whiplash it's been an amazing year at
the movies comment below and let me know
your favorites of 2014 thanks for
watching I'm Meg from Fandango movie
clips wishing you a Happy New Year
filled with more fantastic films